hello rejects I'm Greg with the lovely
the lovely the lovely Luca doorto from
the channel sweet eats you might have
seen his collab together on their
channel you might have seen her on this
channel before well she's back today
before she goes visit some Asian people
in Thailand yeah yeah Thais the Thais
we're gonna watch the trailer for
something I can't believe has actually
been made it's called the emoji movie I
was like all right I gotta watch us are
you good with knowing when to use your
emojis I'm not the best at selecting my
emojis I feel like I'm really good at it
but I think sometimes people miss read
what I'm trying to say so I guess that
would mean I'm probably do you it like
people think like somebody especially
I'm like he like when he covers his
mouth it's like I think he's like
laughing like Kiki but I don't think
that's I don't think that's real I don't
think I don't think it is either
I'm pretty sure hands are like this like
ah yeah I never know when to use an
emoji I don't know if it comes across
like home flirting or if I'm flirting I
don't know what emojis to use I'm just
not lately I just used the the one where
his mouth and his eyes are like this
just like yeah yeah that's what I use
the blank stare sizzling does the blank
faces that's the in level of emotion I
just ask yeah teaser
hello as you can see I'm an emoji anywho
our pleasure to announce our first movie
[Music]
to thrilling forward so bring the family
whoa
doesn't have to be your family the emoji
to a family I can't work like this
these lights I'm melting in here this is
such a loaded no ha finish that sentence
of course this [ __ ] is British for right
now you know I could see this kind of
working now that I saw a teaser trailer
idea I'm think I'm gonna be okay with
that channeling each personality
tailored to each emoji kind of make
sense actually be it set out yep yeah a
little bit of insight I feel it's gonna
be a lot more comedic than the inside
out for sure I mean which emoji would
you say best represents you that's me
right there the one who looks kind of
Asian that uh would steam coming out of
his steam as I always mistake it for
like those old Chinese yeah yeah
chopsticks weird like the hopefully yeah
exactly the old like Fung Shui like like
which face do you think will represent
your your emotions your personality the
best one of those this one or this one
oh yeah let me screen show that send it
to myself so I can include like a video
loose or high yeah like I said anything
this is me when I get around you I'm
wondering if this will actually be good
you see the Angry Birds movie I didn't
was it good I heard it was okay I just
want this to be funny as long as it's
fun have a good time you know I loved
kind of topic serious
did you see Zootopia yeah holy [ __ ]
that wasn't me that was a good animated
movie I feel like the emoji we worked
better if I guess I know it's obviously
gonna be tailored to kids if it wasn't
tailored to kids I feel like we could
have had like a great raunchy like emoji
movie like sausage party like sausage
party yeah that would have been wrong
cuz I got it they got TJ Miller in here
and I feel like TJ Miller is great with
like that kind of humor cuz like they
could have said the word [ __ ] for like a
character that's clearly made of [ __ ]
made of [ __ ]
why is there an emoji for [ __ ] I don't
know I feel like [ __ ] or I feel or I
have to poop or has any text people
sometimes head I have to poop we're
doing a pooping right now where are you
up to
I already never had to use the poop
emoji in my life I used it a lot if I
feel like I need to respond but I have
nothing else that's two edges on the
poop emoji like I'll use that for the
next relationship I get into yeah you
should dry yeah you make me feel well
that'd be great
only communicating through emojis that's
hard that's hard some people do it some
people nail that you do it some people
some people nail that [ __ ] down story
through emojis there's a great review a
trailer isn't it oh Jesus on it yeah
it's like it's on topic it's on
something like that they use the like
lazy one yeah I feel like yeah I thought
that was a great for the trailer too
because I'm sure when people first heard
about this idea they were like this is
this is ridiculous how can you do an
emoji okay so having that personality be
the front and center kind of mocking
this whole idea good marketing good
marketing nicely done
alright guys well it's just read back if
you're new to the channel subscribe
today get accepted you fella reject
Jesse Lucas Horto is on the channel
sweet eats where they do a lot of
healthy baking recipes tasty delicious
healthy or to energetic personalities
blonde brunette
soon they'll have a redhead in there one
day they'll be the Charlie's Angels of
Utah 500 you got to find a redhead I
know putana redheads look at me no feel
I don't some on your right heads just
know so many I know why a variety of
girls just all the time
ganging up on me we're just talking
about this for a video just surrounded
by one
I know you can follow her on Instagram
and Twitter and she has amazing you
don't have a Twitter how are you ever
gonna be successful in this world
without a Twitter
I don't need social media yeah you do
God Jennifer Lawrence is only famous
because she tweets does she actually
tweet I don't think she tweets I don't
think she does anything yeah you don't
need a Twitter it's a rock star but she
has a great Instagram does she I look at
it all the time yeah you do thing I look
at it constantly I mean if you go to my
search you're my top search I love that
that's not really what a woman want to
find that flattery
[Music]